hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten welt heute gibt es kein rezept
video und zwar geht es heute um ein
gewinnspiel
aber morgen also am mittwoch kommt
wieder ein ganz normales rezept video
ich habe letzte woche am samstag mein
gewinnspiel mit der kitchenaid gestartet
und dies ist nach etwas anders gemacht
und muss jetzt aber leider schon heute
einschreiten weil einfach ein bisschen
was aus dem ruder gelaufen ist und zwar
habe ich ja bisher immer so ein
gewinnspiel gemacht ich hab da noch
nicht oft gemacht im schlafzimmer nach
dem zufallsprinzip gemacht und diesmal
habe ich mir gedacht komm überlegen uns
mal was machen was so dass hier jeder
einen kommentar hinterlassen kann und
stellte die meisten likes bekommt er
gewinnt anhalt von mir und von murat war
das ein bisschen naiv gedacht weil ich
hab es hat so überlegt die leute die
kommentieren damals und dann ist es was
lustige ist oder ein gedicht oder eine
geschichte und und dann lacht man
darüber dann liest man sich das wirklich
durch und kommt eben da was einem am
besten gefällt
ich hab mal die andere seite überlegt
also dass es da vielleicht auch leute
gibt die vielleicht lags kaufen können
ich will jetzt keine unterstellt sei es
gekauft aber sowas gibt oder dass es zum
beispiel leute gibt die in verschiedenen
gruppen tätig sind dann alle ihre
gruppenmitglieder dazu animieren für
sich zu leiten
und da kommt natürlich so verschiedene
ungereimtheiten ein bisschen als er sich
nicht ganz fair abgelaufen und es gab
natürlich dann auch noch leute die zum
beispiel instagram account haben und
ganz viele tausend follower haben und da
auch mitgemacht haben weil ich habe ja
eigentlich nur ausgesprochen andere
youtuber dürfen nicht mitmachen
aber ich habe lettern gedacht dass es
eben auch instagram oder facebook leute
gibt eben auch viele follower haben und
habe es dann aber noch als ergänzung in
meine infobox rein geschrieben aber es
kann trotzdem ganz viele nachrichten
privat und auch in meinem shop haben
viele anfragen rosa einfach sli also ich
würde gerne mitmachen aber ich find's
einfach unfair bis läuft und deswegen
möchte ich das jetzt heute so erstmal
enden beziehungsweise einfach
einschalten denn also an der stelle
möchte ich einfach mal sagen dass ich
die ganzen kommentare lese und das alles
sehen was da abläuft und ich finde viele
leute benutzen einfach das internet und
der ist es in anonym und können dann
andere leute einfach total beleidigen
oder angreifen und das artet immer alles
ganz schnell aus wie so ein
schneeballsystem also eine fängt an und
alle anderen ziehen dann irgendwie mit
und zwar habe ich ja da viele
nachrichten bekommen zum beispiel dass
man leute geschrieben habe zähle ich
habe so einen tollen beitrag ich habe
ein gedicht erfunden für dich oder eine
geschichte oder ein witz aber ich habe
einfach nicht so viele freunde die ich
jetzt dazu animieren könnte meinen
beitrag zu leiten und andere die
vielleicht 1000 freunde in ihrer
freundesliste haben unseren gruppen
aktiv sind und vielleicht noch auf einer
facebook-seite werden können die
bekommen die ganzen likes für irgendwas
was sie sich vielleicht kurz ausgedacht
haben und dann stimmt einfach so das
gleichgewicht und es ist einfach was da
habe ich einfach nicht dran gedacht das
tut mir auch leid und ich verstehe auch
man kann ja auch gar nicht mehr als 1000
kommentare lesen um sand zu gucken
welchem kommentar gebe ich jetzt mein
like als ich habe damit gerechnet dass
so viele kommentare zustande kommen und
jetzt im nachhinein betrachtet ist
völlig normal dass es eigentlich gar
nicht so fair ablaufen kann weil die
beiträge die dann schon viele likes
haben sind weiter oben dann macht der
eine vielleicht erst am donnerstag mit
der andere läuft schon seit samstag also
es ist ungleich und ich werde das
gewinnspiel jetzt weiter laufen lassen
allerdings mit bisschen anderen
spielregeln und zwar so nichts die
beiträge die sich also die leute die
sich richtig viel dabei gedacht haben
sich etwas ausgedacht haben und zu recht
sagen jetzt noch viele likes bekommen
haben sollen jetzt nicht leer ausgehen
und zwar werde ich davon die zehn nehmen
die am meisten also die dies ganz wie
der likes haben
dann werde ich aber auch mit einem
zufallsprinzip da gibt es online einfach
so maschinen die das bezahlen ausspucken
und ich muss dann
kommentaren abzählen welcher kommentar
das ist werde ich mit zehn leute einfach
zufällig ziehen und dann nehme ich
einfach nur fünf leute die er den
beitritt noch geteilt haben auf facebook
da hab ich da 25 leute und das wird dann
per zufall ermittelt also stoppt aus sie
einfach samira ziehen oder so
oder macht es dann eben auch online und
ich hoffe und denke auch dass das jetzt
für alle die beste lösung ist und so
also auch wenn man überlegt die beste
entscheidung jetzt ist und das ist
einfach so weiterlaufen und man darf
nicht vergessen es geht wirklich nur um
eine küchenmaschine also und die ganzen
kommentare als ich lese mir abends hatte
murat durch und jemand hat geschehen
celik kannst du wirklich alle durch
diesen ja ich lese alle durchstöbert
lang aber und da ist so viel
zusammengekommen das in wietze dabei ich
lache mich tot drüber ich da ein paar
musste auf matt einen weil es so witzig
sind oder geschichte wie ausgedacht und
autocad nichts ernstes zwischen traum
das alles zu lesen da kam es stunden
damit verbringen
aber es gibt natürlich auch negativ
seite und zwar kam zum beispiel ein
beitrag bei facebook das war total
positiver beitrag da hat einfach jemand
den namen hat die steffi ich werde auf
sein facebook post vor diesem video
löschen das heißt ihr könnt dann auch
nicht mehr nach gucken da die steffi zum
beispiel geschrieben dass sie eben total
gerne backt und ihre tochter sogar
kleine törtchen nennt und es für sie ein
schöneres gibt und dass sie ihre tochter
bekommen hat was so ein wunder und wenn
sie es hier noch gewinnen wird wird es
genauso ein großes wunder
es braucht praktisch eine mutter die
einfach voller liebe daran beitrag
geschrieben hat und haben so viele leute
kommentiert und ihr auch likes gegeben
weil sie gesagt haben das hat mich jetzt
so berührt du kriegst mein leib ich will
dass du gewinnst dickes danke aber
irgendwann einfach eine person die was
negatives geschrieben hat und zwar
geschrieben hast du kannst da ziemlich
einfach ein krankes kind vorschieben
und ich glaube sogar stand drin sein
behindertes kind und dann
ich habe das erst mal gar nicht gesehen
und dann gingen die kommentare los von
wegen
wie kann studierte sitze was
unterstellen usw da habe ich das gelesen
habe gedacht die steffi hat nichts von
behinderten kind geschrieben nichts von
krankheit geschrieben
jetzt kommt ein mensch unterstellt ihr
das einfach anhand von einem foto und
von dem beitrag
ich finde es eine frechheit und so
unverschämt überhaupt sowas zu schreiben
ich meine die person die es geschrieben
hat
ich sage jetzt einfach mal du du weißt
doch gar nicht auf dieses kind krank
oder gesund ist und selbst wenn du es
wissen würde ich wäre es doch kein grund
dafür so was zu schreiben also ich finde
es wirklich richtig böse
und dann gingen die kommentare los ich
glaube daran über 200 kommentare zu
diesem einem bild wo einfach nur der
auslöser war dass eine mutter
geschrieben hat sie wird gerne
kitchenaid gewinnen und das war
eigentlich aus mutterliebe gedacht und
nichts von wegen ich brauche jetzt eure
mitleid oder ich brauche die maschine
ansonsten können wir nicht mehr
weiterleben
also das war also richtig auf
deutschland shitstorm gut deutsch aber
ihr versteht was ich meine
und da ging dann einfach los dann kam
eine idee was auf türkisch geschrieben
hat die eigentlich von dem ganzen post
keine ahnung hatte also das war dann der
dann ein bild von einem jungen
geschrieben ein türkischer junge der
verstorben war vor kurzer zeit das war
ganz schrecklich und hat dann
geschrieben wieso jetzt dieses deutsche
kind mehr aufmerksamkeit bekommt wie das
türkische kind dann ging das ich
rassistische bemerkungen los und
kommentare
also das ist völlig aus dem ruder
geraten und eigentlich total explodiert
und irgendwas aber jemand gestimmt sally
wieso schreibst du nicht ein
und ich stand anna gedacht oh gott was
mach ich jetzt und das ist eigentlich zu
80 prozent einer der gründe wie sich
heute ist dieses video gemacht habe und
als einschreite ich habe jetzt auch den
kommentar gelöscht von ihr ich möchte
euch aber auch das foto gelöscht
aus dem grund weil ich nicht will dass
man die frau ist noch mehr angreift und
für mich ist diese steffi total die
gewinnerin mich aufgrund ihrer likes die
jetzt über 600
ich glaube es gibt jetzt auch keinen
dass sie noch einholen würde
anhand dieser zahl ich bin einfach
zwischen gewinnerin weil sie dieses bild
reingestellt hat über 200 kommentare kam
und kann uns sagen locker ein drittel
der kommentare waren negativ es ging
dann plötzlich um rassismus es ging um
behinderungen es ging und krankheiten
und sie hat das bild trotzdem drin
gelassen und hat sich nicht mal dazu
geäußert sie hat ja auch kommentare
zurück schreiben können oder oder
irgendwas was rechtfertigen oder
irgendwas also ganz ehrlich wenn mich
jemand so persönlich angreifen wird dann
dann sag ich doch auch was zurück ich
lasse mich doch nicht unterdrücken
und sie hat es einfach nicht gemacht sie
jetzt einfach stehen lassen und steht
einfach zu ihrem bild und zu ihrem
posting und das finde ich es für mich
einfach die gewinnerin aufgrund dessen
und steffi auch echt eine fronte die
ganze stadt
die haben dann kommentiert steffi lässt
sich nicht unterkriegen mach weiter und
du bist eine tolle mutter und deshalb
mich total gerührt als obwohl ich dich
nicht mal kerner oder ein kind ich kenne
deine freunde nicht kennen uns hat nicht
nur mich berührt sondern auf ganz viele
andere die dann eben auch geschrieben
haben steffi du bist die erste die man
leiht bekommen hat und ich werde mit
deinem bild licon und das finde ich
einfach so klasse und die person die das
anfangs so negativ kommentiert hat ich
sage jetzt keine namen
vielleicht solltest du einfach mal
deinen kommentar einfach mal
hinterfragen der sagen habe ich da jetzt
vielleicht was falsch interpretiert war
das vielleicht ganz anders und ich habe
ja dieser frau einfach irgendwas
unterstellt also das kann er auch
passieren dass man einfach mal aus dem
affekt heraus etwas schreiben was man
tun sollte denn du weißt nie wer einfach
hinter diesem profil dann steckte weil
ich mir wie verletzlich die person ist
und ganz ehrlich ich bin zwar nicht die
steffi und ich bin auch nicht die mutter
des kindes aber selbst mich hals
getroffen also als mutter ab und zu
schreiben leute auch über die familien
am wasser was ignoriert im lösch es
einfach aber so was kann man echt nett
machen vor allem als fremde person hat
und deswegen steffi stufe mit einer
gewinnerin und murat und nicht lange
überlegt was wir machen und dadurch
jetzt sowieso keine mehr
nun kann aufgrund der über 600 likes
haben jetzt beschlossen dass du auch
eine küchenmaschine gewinnst es wird
zwar nicht die kitchenaid in himbeer als
sein aber du bekommst eine gleichwertige
küchenmaschine einer sehr kalten markt
ich möchte einfach nichts sagen das
mache ich es mit dem privat und ich
denke alle anderen die das video erst
sehen wenn das verstehen das gewinnspiel
läuft ja auch noch weiter und es stehen
jetzt wieder alle chancen offen für alle
alle die sich mühe gegeben haben und
ihre likes gesammelt haben werden jetzt
berücksichtigt alle anderen werden
berücksichtigt aufgrund das
zufallsprinzip und ich habe das jetzt
einfach für mich beschlossen dass ich
das jetzt so machen
außerdem bekommst du stellt das ist
jetzt noch von uns geschenkt wir kommen
schon noch ein bug starter set aus
meinem shop geschenk und du kannst mir
einfach mal schreiben also ich
kontaktiert ich kann einfach mal
schreiben ob du auf eine dafür kate bolt
messen gehen wohl des aktuellen niveaus
und wenn ja kann ich mich da einfach
kontaktieren und dann gebe ich dir
einfach noch karten für dich deine
tochter und eine familie also das finde
ich eigentlich nur gerechtfertigt weil
du jetzt prinzip im prinzip auf meiner
facebook-seite jetzt so viel negative
kritik bekommen hat und das ist so
praktisch die wiedergutmachung und den
kurs habe ich gelöscht und möchte
einfach keine angriffsflächen bieten für
die person und denkt dass ich jetzt so
einfach alles wieder geregelt also ihr
könnt jetzt alle gern noch bei dem
gewinnspiel mitmachen könnt gerne noch
andere beiträge like wenn also auf
gefällt mir drücken und es wird ja auch
per zufallsprinzip entschieden ich
möchte auf jeden fall mal ein video
machen über das soziale netzwerk also
was da so alles abgeht ich bin in
verschiedenen rezept gruppen und auch
anderen gruppen und wenn ich da lässt
was da manchmal los ist muss man echt an
den kopf fassen und denken das sind
erwachsene menschen also manchmal sind
erwachsene menschen echt schlimmer
zueinander wie kinder muss ich sagen vor
allem im internet und da glaube ich
zeige ich immer meine top ten bzw
erzählt euch mal die top ten geschichten
was da so alles erzählt wird gelästert
wird wie die leute sich gegenseitig
angreifen und einfach übereinander herz
sehen ich finde es ganz schrecklich also
man wird es ja auch so persönlich nie
machen stellt sich auch keiner zu
und sagt gerne videos sind total schrott
das macht man dann nur im internet weil
man da nicht direkt vor der person steht
und das finde ich ein bisschen schade
auf jeden fall kommen wieder ein bug
video und ich hoffe das thema legt sich
jetzt und ihr habt alle noch chancen bei
dem gewinnspiel zu gewinnen und habe
zeit bis am samstag ich werd dann
auslosen auch mini video dazu machen
werde sein gewonnen hat ich drücke euch
allen noch ganz fest die daumen wünsche
euch viel spaß morgen bei dem video und
seid ihr alle ganz lieb zueinander und
wenn ihr mal was wenn euch mal was nicht
gefällt schaut einfach hacken ignoriert
es soll zumindest im internet und
beachtet kann einfach nicht statt immer
gleich negativ zu schreiben
also das ist seine botschaft die ich
euch vielleicht mitgehen möchte okay wir
sehen uns morgen wieder bis dahin
tschüss
nein ich sag jetzt mal was ist meine
idee war seine idee mit dem licon ich
von anderen zufallsprinzip
das licht ist gewesen bin dann hast du
solltest jetzt michaela hatten ja und
ich meine idee ja ich bin ich fand es
war nicht unsere idee sagt das ist
unsere abschlagen können so ausartet ich
habe ich gehe davon aus dass facebook
und beim sozialen netzwerk an welt was
muss ich wirklich sagen aber ich sage
einfach durch das war unsere idee habe
dann auch michael freytag